[音楽]
こんばんははじめしゃちょーです
今年の夏もさすがにやらなければと思い
やってまいりました
心霊スポット来ました
今回のカメラマンこちらの方ですどうぞ
ですよどうですか初ですか
霊感みたいなものはいやーね結構見えない
んだけど
感じ取るタイプんー変なの
ということと話させていただきますと僕
ですねなんで心霊スポットそんな毎回行く
かというと
霊感ないんですよ見ないからこそいける
みたいな
逆に見た時終わりなんですけどなんか見な
いっていう自信があるからこそ今まで心霊
スポット後輩とか連れていったりしてたん
ですけども
ここどこでしたっけ黒竹ドライブインと
いう場所でございますここなかなかですね
心霊スポットってのトンネルとか
外にあるもの行ってるんですけど
建物いけることってなかなかなくて
確かに今回特別に許可をいただいてきて
おりますここすごいっすよえ知ってんの
これ有名ですよここま
テレビとかでもやってたような
えーここですね昔は地球環境&エネルギー
資料館っていうより使われてた場所なん
ですけども2008年に閉館した
廃墟になっております
噂ですよ
神様いらっしゃるので適当なこと言えない
ので
噂です噂ロープウェイ乗り場もあるんです
かこれ
なるほどなるほどそこの1階の食堂では誰
もいないのに足音が聞こえてくるあと3辺
ある従業員の休憩室で夜な夜な女性のレが
現れるなどと言われておりますで
間違いなく僕このまま行くと何も出ないん
ですよ大地君ひょっとしたらあるかもしれ
ないですけど
本当に霊感なくてイケてるんで今回ただ
心霊スポットに行くのではなく
霊能力者を今回連れてきております
よろしくお願いします
よろしくお願いしますこんばんはよろしく
お願いしますパトラと申しますお邪魔
いたしますお願いしますよろしくお願い
いたします
霊能力者ということでそうですね
生まれる前から持ってるというかまこう
いうところで見えないものを見えたり
浄化したり高齢したりということでお
手伝いさせていただいてますはいこちら
こそよろしくお願いします
僕霊感がなくて
冷感なくてもお
持ちになってるし
感じる方で見えないだけですよ
ていうのはもう僕にはついているみたいな
あーもうあの見た時に3体ね
持ってきちゃってんだと思います
つい最近だと思う
うんあまりこういう場所は行かない方が
いい時期ってあるんですけどはいそれが
まさに今見て見える方ではないから
感じる方だと思いますのでなるほど
8月中旬なのにおかしいなちょっと行く前
にすごい心配になったんですよ僕大丈夫
ですか大丈夫だと思います足元気をつけて
くださいあなた足弱いのではい
ちょっと今回の企画としては霊能力者の方
と心理スポットに行くとなんかワンチャン
あるんじゃないかっていう不純な同時に
申し訳ないんですけども
一緒にねスポット行ってみたいと思います
彼はなんか大地君っていうんですけども
彼女がついたりしてますかあなたも
そっち側にいるよね
つい最近かな最近なんか
心霊的なとこ行ってますでも
うーん
畑の撮影でトンネルの方にでも心すごい
綺麗だよねだから
[音楽]
そうかな
弱いところって言ったらやっぱり関節的な
ものを腰とか
実際にちょっと
弱ってるかなというところはありますよ
本当に
何かあったら言ってください
早速行きましょうか
[音楽]
Tシャツ見ちゃった
ゆっくり走れー
別の方に聞くとあなたあんまり優しくない
からあんまりつかないって言われたんです
よねただ行くところが悪いやあなた小さい
から私の助言としては今月
来月ぐらいでちょっとこういうのはおやめ
になった方がいいと思うよねちょっと
YouTube的に8月が
稼ぎ時というかそうなんですか夏休みで
子供たちが見たりするんでちょっと今月
だけは体張ってもいいですか
すぐ奴隷化してください
早速中にいこうと思いますよろしくお願い
します
もう大丈夫です
言葉ついてるのは
マジですか
マネージャーさんから借りてきます靴下
だけの香りますちょっと借りてきますね
うわーそんな
声の飛んで言われたらちょっと靴下があり
ます
待って待って
ガチで勝ちだ俺はあと
すっげー奇遇なことに新品のバスケット
シューズ持ってきたね
見て真っ白なんすよ
役立つ時がこの時のために勝ったような
もんよこれ
履かせていただきます
真のピンをまた最近あの先生もおそらく
足元で足首ひねった足首サポーターの大地
君に持ってきてもらってね確かに本当に
こんなこと言われても全く思ってなかった
けど偶然持ってきてますこれはい何
でしょうなんとも運命なことにですね
たまたまバスケットシューズ持ってきまし
たよかったですねこういうとこはもう
ちゃんとしっかり足
ちゃんと踏まないと
逆に変なの吸ってっちゃうから
[音楽]
わかりました
新品です
いいですお金で買えないんですよお
金で買えないでもなんか
本当に
偶然持っててよかったねいつも入ってない
んですよ
新品だっていいじゃない別にあなたお金
持ってるからでもこれはさやっぱ自分の
あれだよね勘だよねちゃんとこういうのを
用意してらっしゃるっていうのはんという
か最近本当に
足首捻って
こんな心霊スポットある
こちらなんだよね
左あってかこっちひねりましたそっちだよ
ね
足元だいぶいかつくなりましたけど大事
ですじゃあ行きましょうか
はい
よろしくお願いしますお願いします
よろしくお願いしますやっぱり
使われてないと草が多いすぎるからそう
ですねそれもまた怖いですね
すごいな確かに草の量
[音楽]
なんだけど
先生は逃げましたけど
ちょっと待ってちょっと待って
あの人いるわ
頑
張ろう本当可愛いですか
可愛いまでは見えないけどハゲとして
見えるね
はい行きましょう切り替え早い
どういう位置にできるのこれどういううわ
すごいね
[音楽]
私は大丈夫だけどあなたとか俺も大丈夫に
なりたいですちょっと近くで見ると怖いね
足元気をつけてね行きましょうそれでは
参りましょうかはいね
はい
[音楽]
普段は撮影禁止になってる
開けます
[音楽]
こんな感じになっております
すごい
[音楽]
やばいまだここじゃないからそうですよ
失礼します
[音楽]
降りれるんだ
こっちだあそこの窓
出すこの窓からだったねさっきも消えたの
はちょっとそっちぐらいまで行ってみ
ましょうかちょっとこの水の上では私も
そうなんで
そこは危ない
多分どこも危ないです
[音楽]
汗でいかない方がいいとこ行ってますね
そこのここのあたりですね
結構
[音楽]
女の人じゃないの
さっき見た人とは別ってことですかね
いや
わかんないです
若い男の子だった
声が
聞こえます
本当
え触られた後すぎばいやいやいやいや
いやいや
[音楽]
走ってる
6歳ぐらいかな5歳ぐらいかな
[音楽]
大丈夫ですか大丈夫ですか
気をつけてください
えあなた大丈夫
[音楽]
左足
施術
後ろ
って
言ったよねちょっと
戻りましょうちょっと戻ります
最近どっちかというと事故物件に一人で
泊まってるやつ
だからあっち行けない理由っていうのが
わかりましたこれ裏着物だと思います行っ
てみましょうか行ける勇気ありますか
僕どこでも行きます
はいライトだからこれ
何これいつもの現象でしょじゃあいつもの
現象ってなんか出る前にこうなるじゃん
設定があれとかじゃないんだよ
これになる時
霊現象が起きる時なんですねこれねマジ
ですか
ポルターガイストとか
ラップ現象とかその
電磁波まだねマジじゃないですか
光る
弱い
消える本当にこれしかない
えっマジっすか
じゃあちょっと3人で行ってきますはい
なんで今そこ守っててください
下の方がやばいっておっしゃってたので
ちょっと
気持ち悪いんじゃなくて
ここここが問題だと思うここですか
この遊び場的なところ私も
[音楽]
右足が麻痺してます今ですか
足痛くないです私右足痺れちゃってます今
のところ大丈夫です
足首サポーターが効いてますなるほど
[音楽]
すごいなぁ
漫画が置いてあります
進撃の巨人誰ここで呼んだ
[音楽]
今ガラスの落としてません
奥からしましたね今そう今
走った誰か
走ってないと思いたいですこっちの奥って
まだ行ってないでしたっけここ
多分ね
行きたかったらいいよ」って
1回上に戻ります
[音楽]
誰かが止まった
どういうこと
ちょっとじゃあ止めて止めてきますねなん
で
嘘じゃんちょっと待ってくれよ
[音楽]
これは
12時
7分ですかね
止めないと止めないと止めないと
マジで
[音楽]
待って待って待って
タッチ悪すぎだろ普通に
えこれ
誰かが仕掛けてたってことあーやばい
ちょっと1人無理だなこれ戻ります
[音楽]
頑張りましたちょっとねえっ
突然止まりました
突然
止まっちゃうってさ携帯よりも自分なんだ
よね
自分が止めたりするの
そういう
木をお持ちなんだと思いますありがとう
ございました本当にもう今日は
怖かったですね
霊感ないとか言ってるんですけど
先生とお話しして
実はあったなっていう
本当にあるので
ちゃんと先生がこういうことあるって言っ
てくれたからあそれがそれだったのって
いうか
本当ありがとうございますありがとう
ございます勉強になりましたあなたと等身
大見れてどういう人間っぽいですか
人とは違うキャッチングするのにアイデア
から何か早いといいアイデアが出てくる人
ですねだからそれを止めないで来年はもう
大体的に成功しますからそうそうだから
この
8月急いでよりもいいからやっぱり
体を休みになって
目標というよりもあなた先に進んじゃう人
だったら
目標ないんですよアグレッシブにも
あんまり
拾っていくでしょうそこはね天才だと思い
ますよただ
体
怖いからあの
間接的なこととやっぱりやるだけ
聞くけどやらない時は天国から
0か100ですね
あのいい機能の着方だと思います
静岡と東京で両方落ち持ってて3億円のお
家買ったんですよ静岡ですえっすごいじゃ
ないですかそこは
仮装じゃないしてもらったらめちゃくちゃ
いいって言われたんですけど
東京に住んでるお家が
結構悪いっていう
[音楽]